[Music]
have you guys seen that trend primarily
on tick-tock but it leaks over on other
social media platforms where people are
doing the like never have I ever thing's
not it now there's this one version of
it where um we're just gonna watch it
maybe it's going we are gonna be playing
and mainly it would just be me and Nikki
why for a women is it the women I want
to see more for ages that I've seen the
one for for black people I've seen that
one you make one for Asians I just don't
know why agent problems are Asian
problems people call you Wuhan back oh
yes my fingers up because you grew up in
Texas you say you've experienced a lot
of racism true so you do this the
different by corner you like that's true
oh it's just mainly like name-calling
and I'm like well that's just one finger
and then I don't know I haven't really
been police at the same experience I did
but I was doing graffiti gangsta have
you ever ate like freaking dried
cockroaches never you never Chinese
parable for that please have you ever
eaten a dog that's like Asian stairs
that's true yeah I would keep my fingers
up have you ever driven poorly yet saran
wrap okay remote control that's a good
one yeah well fingers that go down yes
saran wrap on the Vulcan job down Oh do
you make very stinky food all the time
yes then put a finger down do you have
slippers for the house specific do you
take your shoes off when you walk in
your house no yes oh I do only because
my non-asian wife tells me to do
something if I had it my way where where
I'm shoes also grew up with she was in
the house my entire life until I met you
and then we started going to your
friends homes and then I learned I'm
like yeah that was unsanitary does
Barton Joe to blame for the reason why I
can't wear shoes in mine yes their fault
I've never ate boiled ginger yes when
you're sick
yes you
Tiger Balm on your aching joints yes
we're giving you so many good ideas for
a tick-tock okay when you're sick and
regardless of symptoms did you just get
given Tylenol
does your dad kiss you on the lips and
say he loves you no Asian I've been
kissing Tyco on the lips
hey cute I used to kiss Isaac on the
lips and then I just got so far all
night you're too old for this I used to
kiss tight couple I don't kiss him
anymore why he doesn't like me that like
that he does you got to catch him and
then kiss no you got a respect take us
boundaries I gotta ask him for consent
now he's the age of consent yeah okay
well speaking of consent and things like
that bro let's get into this video this
tick-tock so your so the way that this
video that I have in front of me is the
woman in the middle is the original
audio and then the woman on the and like
they did like the thing right got you
the lip-synching and then just take a
look at this woman here especially
towards the end okay and then Nikki
let's do it ladies I think we have to
share our truth this is gonna be put a
finger down female reality style please
do at this use the sound I want to
follow along put a finger down if you've
been drugged put a finger down if your
friends have been drugged Oh woman a
finger down if you've been followed put
a finger down if you want to your car
with your keys or pepper spray as a
weapon put a finger down if you check
your backseat lock your doors the second
you get inside your car put a finger
down if you've been sexually touched
inappropriately put a finger down if you
did something with a man that you didn't
want to do because you were scared to
say no for your own safety
put a finger down if you've experienced
something really scary or even illegal
and you were scared to report it because
you didn't think anybody would listen
put a finger down if when you hear see a
man running behind you you freak out put
a finger down if something bad happened
to you and the men who were around that
you thought would protect you didn't oh
wow this actually does make me tear up
wait a minute
you were - yeah that's all sad where do
we hear about this before yeah well
maybe I think your story but I forgot
sookay was an important so sad no I
didn't I didn't get that I didn't get I
was protected during that time
thankfully but I couldn't walk I was all
rhyme I was only stopping by my cousin's
party to to like say hi and I wasn't
gonna drink because I had to work the
next day and I had like a sip of like
water that was there but it was sitting
on the counter that like people were
walking by their taste like anything no
I think you gonna tell no what was your
truck story
well my drug story is not um by a man it
was someone that I was with that was it
gave me a drug unknowingly and then
later I found out and I freaked out but
that it wasn't like with the intention
to like take advantage take advantage of
me it was just like oh we're gonna party
it up right let's party it up here drink
this water bottle and so it's more of
like a like a frat boy type of deal I
hang keys drank this and later it wasn't
by a man about me like that about this
entire one that I I was like well it's
not different contact it's a different
context but I have been drugged on the
what's dangerous about women getting
drugged though is that like you can
potentially wake up with a dude you
didn't want to mm-hmm
and then it could have been like an
innocent party like you guys your
friends like whether this party there's
[ __ ] drugs in that water and then like
she's too [ __ ] gone to take care of
you or be a good [ __ ] drug host and
then you wake up the next day you're
like I don't want to [ __ ] this dude what
the [ __ ] well I have been in a situation
where I gots I was very drunk and this
guy that I was with kept feeding me
alcohol and next thing I know I was so
[ __ ] wasted and he was having sex
with my body and I'm just like [ __ ] and
I remember I had just started my period
and then I went to the bathroom and I
just there was blood everywhere and I'm
like what the [ __ ] just happened my
friend got he got drugged
at a rave and those this big-ass dude
that was dragging his body behind the
bleachers and everyone found it and they
we ran up and we started [ __ ] that
dude up like crazy we think he was gonna
like do him yeah cuz being dropped is
just dangerous it's just so many
predators out there you don't know what
the hell to do yeah so like with that
particular guy that it happened um like
I had we were at a party right and then
me and my friend end up going because I
like I said we're just [ __ ] drunk and
then I felt so dirty and like just
violated and violated - but like my
weird way of like making it right was
like I need to see him again and have
like some sort of relationship to make
this go away like a Stockholm Syndrome
also like to make it seem less rapey
you're like oh yeah we were seeing each
other through a relationship now was he
being taken exactly lie to yourself to
kind of stomach what happened exactly
what I was like and yeah it was it was
really it was really weird you know
what's crazy is when you think about
like history right like rape was so
normalized to the point where it's just
disgusting like if you think about it
was pretty normal if you were a peasant
that other warring armies can come into
town and take all the women and kids and
kill all the guys and rape the hell out
of all the girls that was normal for
hundreds of years and still you know
kind of like we just got out of that
phase and so now we're finally becoming
more civil but we still have that like
Rea penis in some guys that try to do it
who's that it's power it's not about sex
it's about power and what sucks too is
that I think sometimes when you look at
it right the perpetrators might be like
some bad guys but then good guys get
tied into it as like you're a part of
this rape culture even though like
you would never do such a thing oh when
they generalize like all guys do this I
see because I am against that to it I
want to find these guys and kill them
and catch them and do all that stuff and
I think we're all in the same you know
like we're all in the same fight us and
women like everybody want wants these
criminals to get caught and and all
these weirdos that are stalking women
well it just it sucks when like that
last one
the last finger that should put down
where it's like you know that something
bad has happened to you and the men
around thinking you they would protect
you they just don't show up and that's
so [ __ ] common
that's why I really like that's I really
like these girls getting into like
jiu-jitsu or kickboxing or some sort of
combat sport or even powerlifting now
because now instead of depending on
someone else for your own safety
it's not about depending it's about like
like if there's like a shift in power
right especially as a woman like this is
something unfortunately you're never
gonna understand yeah you're never gonna
understand how it feels to be so
vulnerable so small so fragile in a
moment where like a man comes into just
like with this present psyche over
you're already over it takes like he's
alpha so there's no way of like you like
it's so subtle to that no matter how
strong how [ __ ] badass [ __ ] you are
it doesn't matter every woman has
experienced this [ __ ] practically every
woman thankfully there's some that
haven't but like in those situations
like yeah you want to protect yourself
you want to say something you don't want
to [ __ ] let it happen to you like you
don't want to just take like sit back
and be like hey guys this happened you
know yeah yeah not that's not the case
it's like that's why in situations where
there's other people around and they're
seeing this that you're observing like
this is wrong you wish they what I
stepped in yeah yeah not even that but
then like in that moment like when as
like the girl the victim or whatever is
actually like looking like seeking help
and no one steps up its really [ __ ]
tragic that's not that's what I'm saying
though so like I think like I think it
is [ __ ] up that no one stepped in but
I think not just men and women I think
all like kids you know like kids that do
it after school martial arts programs
I think everyone's safety
if they can be the first person to be
responsible for their own safety it
helps out a lot well that makes sense
yeah I think Bart's talking about just
education in the sense of violence
education yeah so like if because one of
the reasons why people don't step in is
they're scared not because they don't
want to or whatever I think a lot of the
times have you heard of the that study
it's called like dispersed
responsibility or some [ __ ] like that
where like there will be experiments of
people in danger but because there's a
big crowd a lot of people just are less
likely to help yeah because they think
someone else will help right but then
people that are alone in that situation
are more likely to help because they
feel responsibility so if it was maybe
you were getting harassed in a train and
it's only one other guy he might help
but we also don't know how scared that
guy is so I think that's something to
take into consideration if they're
untrained they never got into a fight
before it's completely scary and there's
fight or flight some men won't just run
cuz they're scared and some guys will go
in and try to kill I think it's not fair
to make that a responsibility of a
bystander but I do feel like in
everyone's hearts they're totally
against this and they hate this and they
don't want to witness this and it sucks
when you it sucks that now we're
painting a whole gender a certain light
because of these [ __ ] yeah it happens
like women do this to men as well like
for sure it's just and I agree with how
you're saying like well yeah we don't
know how the other person is
experiencing that situation either which
okay that's valid but I think in like in
terms of like the power dynamic like
even though the man is is afraid in that
situation like no matter what he has
like more of a protection or like he's
able to send it though female especially
if like you're just much smaller than
the person that's yeah but not
everyone's a hero like what if he's
afraid of losing his life that's not my
circumstance either like it might I was
just like in a group situation like
someone making really sexist mean marks
and then I'm just trying to laugh it off
to them uncomfortable and then
one steps in and says like hey man like
it's not funny or whatever like because
I don't want to say it cuz then I don't
want to be like like oh she's such a
prude what a party pooper or whatever
but then it's just like really mean and
then you just go to the bathroom and you
know so I try to compose yourself and
like you kind of like psych kind of
psychologically go like maybe I'm taking
it the wrong way or I'm personalized or
too much you know you try to talk
yourself out of it but like cuz no one
else is stepping in so you're like well
if they don't think it's wrong enough to
step in and maybe I'm maybe I am the
[ __ ] or something it's it's difficult
to say cuz let's say no one it was
difficult to empathize because they
don't know what it's like to be a woman
right cuz now at my age all I think I'm
better at seeing someone uncomfortable
and being like hey we gotta stop this
but before I think it was completely
self-absorbed and oblivious so I might
not be keen to someone's pain right and
then there's another thing as someone
might notice it but they're coward and
then someone might let be scared to say
anything because of social pressure
there's so many things but then I think
the expecting someone to empathize and
understanding you completely is a
difficult argument to make because if
you don't communicate and explain that
to these individuals also then they
can't have the responsibility and burden
of protecting you so I think that's
what's going on right now is that a lot
of trying to educators good yes I know
that it was so prevalent I knew like I
don't know that no one knows yeah
I'm not surrounded by those guys or I
wouldn't do these things so I'm blind to
it that's like for me more so I want
everyone to be responsible for their own
safety like what G alright if I see in
any one [ __ ] what they're for sure I'm
gonna kill that [ __ ] but there's
a lot of times she's by herself
so she if she can be protected or if she
can at least run away or to have some
sort of understanding of moving removing
herself easy not to be a black belt in
jujitsu or whatever but if she at least
knows how to some basic self-defense how
to get away
this already highlighted how many women
already do that for the example like do
you grab your keys or pepper spray when
you're walking to your car like that is
so common for us and that that's kind of
what you're saying like we are taking
responsibility but that's not
responsibility if you don't train with
the pepper spray if you're not like
shooting like I'm talking about actual
knowledge and me owning that knife a
kitchen knife versus me understanding
how to be a swordsman is different like
I'm not empowered by my knowledge I
think by this though it's kind of like
spreading awareness to where people can
first see the problem and hopefully what
they it's like let's educate the society
better so we can all do better at
helping women out because like now I
know how prevalent like perversion and
these crazy [ __ ] are like I'm I'll be
even more aware to see like hey does
this girl feel comfortable with this guy
sitting next to her or whatever who do I
gotta [ __ ] up today versus before I'm
like oh yeah it should be it's the
[ __ ] 21st century women can take care
of themselves like everyone's equal like
collecting this whole equality myth does
make me feel that women can handle
themselves cuz they've been handling
themselves instead of me feeling like
maybe I'll be stepping on their toes if
I'm too chivalrous and I'm too stepping
in I'm not letting them be their own
person and defending themselves
I think these conversations are super
super helpful though because like until
people start having these types of
conversations where you know women are
being candid and like the examples that
you know those those fingers are
relating to like there are varying
degrees of those different types of
examples that whether they're micro
macro are like very strong or whatever
like if in the obliviousness you know if
you don't if you weren't aware of things
then you're just not aware right yeah if
I don't put my mentality into what would
a sex predator to you because I'm not
that like I won't pay attention to
things that maybe women can see more or
are aware of because one they're the
they're the victim and then two they
understand what sex predators and you
live it every day
just way more naive right like I'm aware
that it's dead I'm aware people can do
reduce it's like something like over
there it's happening over there not
everybody every woman in your life and
that's totally yeah you know the there's
a huge part of like on my yellow I would
love to learn like I apologize if I've
done things in the past to not be aware
of certain things but the only way I'll
learn is if somebody honestly schools me
for sure and if I'd like an honest
conversation with women whether it's in
your own community or generally speaking
in our society like those little nuances
that can keep us aware of those things
will help us help yeah that's why I
don't think it should go to the level of
up men or like oh man like it should be
just this discussion of like because I
think that that's what was the most
eye-opening when the me to movement
first started was a lot of these men
just weren't aware that every single
woman in their circle went through these
things and knew and that we had all
accepted it as just normal and we also
don't see our buddies in dates and how
they interact with women alone so that's
the other issue too it's kind of like um
the kind of like subtle culture like
sprat boy culture you know like or like
you'd be in a car and then like oh that
girl's so hot let me honk at her like
things like that like those are all tiny
little moments of like what's being
predatory because I mean like it's a
loud noise and if you were alone and
there's a group of car full of guys
doing that yeah I could see how that's
really scary yeah the super scare was
jogging one time and this car up guys
pulled up behind me like on the side of
the road like while I was jogging I was
[ __ ] terrified because I didn't have
any pepper spray or anything I was like
hey I'm like I'm gonna kidnap right now
okay good and they really just wanted to
like holler at me and like honk and like
scare me or whatever but it was so
[ __ ] scary just idiots yeah I know a
girl that almost got kidnapped like she
was at a bus stop and a van pulled up in
sliding door guys ran out and then the
bus came right when she was struggling
and then they threw her out of the thing
and then drove off oh the bus driver
came out ran out everyone out of the bus
came and helped yeah so
[ __ ] like that happens it's not it's not
a movie like [ __ ] crazy
so yeah I was talking to one of my black
crewmates about the idea for example
there's an analogy of what like anti
racism is versus like non racing right
and he used the analogy of like when
you're at the airport you're standing on
one of those things that just constantly
moves you're not maybe moving you're not
walking in that direction but the fact
that you're not doing anything you're
still flowing with the system because
still benefiting from it and I think
that same thing can apply for you know
understanding like what women may be
feeling I may not be a sexual predator
therefore I'm not like walking with the
thing but if I stand in a society where
we don't pay attention we don't actively
choose to walk the other way in help of
women then I'm maybe aiding the system
so what we have to do is switch our
mindset to understand that our
complacency is not enough and rather we
have to really educate and go the other
way in order to make like good change I
want to know who these [ __ ] guys are
so we could [ __ ] them up there you go
here we go it's not that I never thought
that way I always want to do that it's
easy to tell they have plucked eyebrows
[Laughter]
[Music]